foreign
but I do come at it from a practical
perspective being probably the only
person in the room with a bionic
enhancement she looks around
my exploration of future humans began
about a decade ago when I'm in a man
who had an ear surgically implanted into
his
um even if we're technically on the
clinically can fix some of our
shortcomings as humans we still need to
think about which aspect of Being Human
actually are shortcomings which of these
changes might actually promise more than
they can uphold and what should be
considered when we change ourselves in
order to change into something better
rather than just something different and
I did pretty much what anybody here
would do on meeting a man with an ear in
their arm I asked them the question why
it looked at me with this this big smile
on his face and he said
oh why not
[Music]
[Music]
Francis fukuyama famously wrote the book
I'll post you my future where he throw
every argument he could imagine on the
wall to try to argue that human
enhancement was really bad it was risky
it would be having a lot of bad effects
on society but deep down there was this
argument that it might change what it
really means to be a human in such a way
that is not appropriate for humans to
want to do that change now transhumanism
as a moment would respond by saying no
no I wanted to change myself is one of
the most human things ever that's close
to the core what it means to be a human
trying to become better maybe failing at
it but still trying now there is still a
lot of risk involved in changing our
inner self you would really want to be
very careful before you start modifying
bodies on a large scale we have seen in
the past that many Technologies over
promise but there's also another
interesting link to existential risk
many of the earliest people were
concerned about existence of threats do
you mind we're also transhumanists and
that might seem very strange because
aren't transhumans with techno optimists
who thinks that we can solve everything
with some Nano machines in the future
why would they go on about total
Extinction or worse things and the
reason is of course if you're really
optimistic about the future you really
want to get there and you want to
safeguard it and what may want to make
sure it happens
you might also be open to radical
changes and if you can have a radical
change for good you can also perhaps
have radical change for bad for the
worse so you really want to safeguard
against that and then comes with finally
the cherry on top if you're optimistic
about the future you also think that we
can do something about the threats
facing humanity and get to the lovely
Futures that might be possible if you
think the future is meh in that case why
save it and besides if you think you
contact should do anything useful to
improve our chances well why are we even
talking maybe we should just go to the
pub and then a drown our sorrows well
the transhuman is optimistically that
maybe there is something we can do and
the future could become radically well
is a good reason to also try to fix
things like bio weapons nuclear weapons
asteroid impacts and trying to make sure
that if we get artificial intelligence
it's safe and beneficial and aligned
with our interests
foreign
[Music]
victim to clunky first generation
therapies that could have side effects
a majority of Anti-aging products are
patent pending that means that they
haven't been
authorized they're still waiting for
their patents and that's a very serious
thing
so because that's why the largest group
I put is gather information sit back and
wait let other people be the guinea pigs
don't do anything to your mind or body
that you don't need because it could
cause an adverse reaction
so now we come to the point of
biohackers
what about biohackers those who are
hacking their body in and putting um
maybe magnets in their fingers or chips
in their body well that's very
interesting and Kevin Warwick and Steve
Mann both good friends of mine and who I
respect and value very much are thought
leaders in that cyborg organization of
the human biology that's very
interesting but it's not about living
longer and it's not about taking charge
or being the the master of your fate and
the captain of your ship in the uh
journey of longevity how we navigate
that is very important
the difference between the Cyborg and
the transhuman is an important topic
when we're talking about life and death
the cyborg is not a concept a theory
it's not a philosophy it's more a
theoretical approach to
um the mechanization or the augmentation
of the human that is a concept it's not
actual
process the transhuman is part of an
evolution of human of our biology as we
merge with machines so there are two
different concepts they overlap a bit
but I wanted to clarify that that the
cyborg is not actively participating in
enhancement and augmentation it's more
of a passive approach the transhuman is
an active approach in looking at human
evolution and merging with machines and
enhancing Augmentin
at this point in my talk I'd like to
mention a few theories that are practice
based one is morphological Freedom the
concept of morphological freedom is that
you have the right to augment to enhance
your body
as long as it doesn't hurt or damage
anyone else or the environment
likewise
a person
ought never to be coarse to augment to
enhance
their body if they do not choose so just
because some people want to live a
longer life and maybe upload or or
coexist as avatars in in cyberspace does
not mean that everyone has to
diversification is extremely important
not only in our investment in our
longevity but also in our attitude about
other people
foreign
[Music]
and you can imagine a 21st century
totalitarian regime a 21st century
Stalin that you know Stalin worked
mainly with social engineering
he maybe wanted to
re-engineer human biology but he
couldn't he dreamed about creating a new
man a new human the new Soviet but he
only had
social engineering so in the end when
the Soviet Union collapsed you still
have human beings like they were in 1917
and we start again
in the 21st century a new Stalin might
have the ability first to really
re-engineer the body
down to the level of DNA and create
new human species and perhaps even to
create completely inorganic life forms
so we can imagine millions of years of a
new evolutionary track beginning with
some 21st century Stalin and this is
extremely frightening especially because
these kinds of people they think in
extremes you know I talk a lot with
Scientists who are developing these
Technologies whether it's crispr and
genetic engineering whether it's Ai and
most of these people
um they think not only in in beneficial
terms but also in very narrow terms like
I'm doing my research in order to help
cure Parkinson's disease
they it's it's a it's a limp of the
imagination
to think what would the worst politician
on Earth
do with the technology that I'm
developing
but as a historian rather than as a
biologist or as a computer scientist
this is the way my mind thinks when
somebody tells me how they are now using
crispr uh to try and overcome Parkinson
I think what would Stalin have done with
it
foreign
[Music]
since you got your prosthetic so um as
these guys say I think to be human is to
be explorative and adventurous and to
adapt but also it's to be varied so uh
one thing I can say is that there is
somebody else in the world with a hand
exactly like mine and I don't think
anyone else can say that so
just thinking about the different types
of technology and what we can Implement
if we start to all wear bionic hands
then we all have the same hand and we
take away something that is very crucial
to us being humans which is that we are
all different
so how do we we need to make sure that
we maintain that identity and that being
able to be our own unique people and we
don't become some sort of identical
clones which is definitely a very
extreme ideal but it's not something you
know as a
as a concept I think we can all agree
that we don't want that so how do we let
technology adapt our bodies and how do
we become enhanced by technology but
without becoming identical
so the definition of a human has to
include room for variation
and do you consider your hand to be
human or
um no it's become part of me in the
sense that it's a possession that I care
a lot about and at times I've had you
know negative reactions if somebody's
touched it when I didn't want them to in
a possibly in a similar way to if
somebody picked up my phone that I
didn't know
so in a way it's become part of me but
it's not it's not human Okay so going
from this starting point of what we
understand a human being to be uh should
should we enhance ourselves
um
Nikki if I can go back to you first
actually because
um obviously you're on the panel and a
lot of people would think that your hand
is a an enhancement uh first of all do
you
do you consider it that way
um I think it's an adaptation for me uh
um
you could say it was an enhancement
because it enabled me to do a few things
that I couldn't do before I had it so
um just to give you some background I
was born without my right hand and then
I got this one a year ago when I was 29
so I I don't really learned how to do
everything in life without it and then I
learned how to do everything in life
with it so that I had that choice
um so in that sense it does enhance me
slightly
but I would
as well as this being an enhancement
that I've obviously embraced I could
never argue that we shouldn't enhance
ourselves because I imagine everybody in
this room already has you know if
anybody's taken the contraceptive pill
they have made a choice and they have
chosen to enhance themselves by not
getting pregnant or they've been
vaccinated and they've chosen to enhance
themselves by not getting rabies I don't
know
um so we already do things that prolong
our lives and make us last longer in
this world I don't think anybody would
turn around and say actually I don't
want my great uncle with cancer to have
chemotherapy I'd rather he just died and
was you know part of natural selection
so there's no way I would argue that we
shouldn't enhance ourselves
[Music]
do you know you will glad to tell you
this I learned from some collection of
text ideological debates and practical
experiments you know that Stalin tried
already to do this in the late 20s
Stalin was convinced by some stupid
biologist that we come back in Nations I
don't know how to create a perfect
worker which can read write Elementary
but it's too stupid to organize socially
to rebel by coupling humans and apes
and they tried to do it he sent the
delegation to Congo they import about 30
gorillas I think eight and typical male
chauvinism women eight of course and
then yeah
and then and then they selected four
very strong Russian
strong farmer men they made them
copulate okay it didn't work well I was
gonna say and that's how I came to be a
biologist yeah yeah yeah and then Stalin
had to discover that this scientist was
really a British spy you know the story
and see but but what I'm saying is that
Stalin was already forget about
so-called egalitarianism of Communism
what egalitarianism Stalin was the first
who consciously tried to create a
specific race of workers who just work
with modest Kitty food without protest
and so on once we have Life 2.0
this retroactively changes also in our
view not in reality what life the first
life is it because life becomes just a
combination of transparent algorithms
biological and so on and so on and
that's my problem with would you agree
you will with liberal conservatives I
cannot call them in another way like
Jurgen habermas whose solution is since
brain Sciences today by penetrating our
brain and manipulating our DNA are
threatening our ethical
self-understanding we should put a limit
on science we should simply say Bill
McKibbon who wrote a book enough like
this should be the limit but what I'm
saying is that once for example sorry
you again I cannot
once I can I can through some through
some surgery or whatever technical means
chemical change your
a mind that you become more brutal more
decisive more intelligent this means
that already before I intervened your
mind was
functioned at this level it was just
different chemistry and so on so I think
that with post-humanity nature also will
in some sense no longer be
lecture it will become another mechanism
second Point Earth
what is your your Final Solution
namely with this that the big focus on
your work
post human whatever they
are namely uh
like what it maybe you wrote after your
book on homo Deus but what intrigues me
what is the Real Horror for me but maybe
there is some other emancipatory
potential it's so-called wired brain
neuraling and so on the idea because our
basic idea of human Freedom it is most
basic is even if
I mean change can do nothing you don't
control my thoughts I can think what I
think but even the moment you get direct
interaction between my flow of thoughts
and a machine of course as you all said
wonderfully immediately the scientific
manipulators will bring a good medical
example to justify it like already said
a guy who couldn't
real move his penis they manipulate it
now thinking about it or he could do it
but what other things can you do because
if you can control movements outside
just with your brain it goes also the
other way around and what I don't have a
good answer is is this really the end of
Freedom what is freedom is freedom just
what we call some philosophers the
user's illusion or now I expect the
answer now what you what you you said
trust in humans and Faith you know faith
in humans yes okay I have faith in you
to provide the answer yeah
foreign
[Music]
the best way to describe this is with a
with an example of a guy called Neil
Harbison does anybody know who Neil
Harbison is
a couple of folks so Neil Harbison is a
colorblind artist and he has an antenna
surgically implanted into his head that
allows him to hear color
now the wild thing about Neil Harbison
is that our antenna he's had it for over
a decade it's now surgically implanted
into his skull before that it was a
wearable device and for Neil that that
antenna is no longer a tool or
technology he sees it quite literally as
an organ going up to Neil and touching
his antenna is like if I went up to you
sir and I try to touch your nose you'd
find it kinda odd and he's so integrated
into his body's schema that he now
dreams in Sono chromatic dreams so he'll
have these dream states where all of the
colors in his dream will match the uh
the agency of the um the device that
that sends these light waves to sound
waves through his skull
and again Neil is an outlier but he
talks about being psychological cyborgs
you know you guys are going oh this
cyborg thing is kind of stupid it's kind
of weird it's kind of Fringe but you
know we love to say I bet you all have
iPhones in your pockets you know nestled
next to your genitals or next to your
heart
so to a degree that all makes us cyborgs
question mark
and we'll we'll get to that shortly
because the stuff that I really am
interested in is when it does affect
neurophysiology neuroplasticity when
when these sorts of devices change the
relationship in the brain where we start
to accept that this is no longer a
external tool technology devices is
actually part of our selves
and the place I saw that most
beautifully demonstrated was was after
an event very much like this there was a
guy the late great Nigel Ackland does
anybody know who Nigel Ackland is a
couple of guys at the back they are my
friends so of course you know Nigel
Ackland for those who don't know was the
pioneering pilot of the B bionic
prosthetic limb so he had this beautiful
fiberglass prosthetic limb and I used to
witness who would stand on stages like
this and Show everybody's his bionic
prosthetic limb and he was he was a
working-class man he lost his arm in a
uh in a factory accident and people
would look with desire
at this fiberglass object that he was
holding up in the sky and I would see
people come up to him afterwards and and
grab him outside of the the speaker's
tent and go oh my God
how do I get one of those
they had this kind of weird techno
fetishism for what they perceived to be
a vision for the future of humanity
and Nigel Nigel would look at him with a
rye smile and he would go uh well mate
it's the most exclusive club in the
world and it's going to cost you an arm
or a leg to get in
so you've got to pick
you know a lot of people would ask an
angel do you feel enhanced are you
enhanced by having the prosthetic limb
you lost your arm yes but now you have
this beautifully designed prosthetic
from bionic do you feel enhanced and in
answer to that question he would rotate
his wrist 360 degrees and say well I'm
not enhanced but I'm certainly
differently abled and anybody who does
think I'm enhanced should realize that
being able to turn your wrist 360
Degrees becomes a real challenge when it
comes to wiping your own ass
foreign
[Music]
transhuman and post-human life be like
and the only sensible answer I can I can
give you is I don't know but one of the
many reasons for stressing
recalibration is that by raising hedonic
set points it's not necessary for you or
almost anyone else to sacrifice their
existing values and preferences uh
crudely it just means that you can wake
up in the morning uh feeling in a
fantastically uh good mood and pursue
whatever you consider most valuable or
worthwhile as now that's a rather
bio-conservative answer in practice I
think uh Mastery of our reward circuitry
intelligence amplification radical life
extension is going to transform the
nature of uh of of life in ways that uh
far beyond the pleasure pain axis but uh
yes I regard a precondition of any
civilized society is that we get rid of
uh
involuntary suffering any state below
hedonic zero